hey guys good morning
it's been a while since I checked in and just did just like
a general update video
I can hear my kids yelling at each other
usually when I get on here I'm like
we've got important things to discuss
let's unpack some shit
so it's been a really long time since I've just done a general update
we just got back from an amazing trip to Vermont with my sister and her family
my sensory kiddo uh
had a really tough time
I don't think snowboarding is gonna be
I don't think the winter sports are gonna be thing
but I've been a skier my whole life
I had an amazing time
that being said
it's really great to be home
I'm excited to be back in my house
I have a lot of laundry to do
we are getting ready to do school
and we have Charleston Wine and Food Festival coming up this weekend
which is a huge food festival here in Charleston
and I'm going to be a social media ambassador for it
it swarms get excited
so check out my Instagram
I'm gonna be posting all of the live updates from it
and all sorts of fun little outfits
with that being said
I don't think I've done my hair in about like 9 days
and today I got to use my first round of hand me downs from big brother for Levi
and it kind of blew my mind how fast
these kids are growing